Der
Ast auf die erde zu und könnte sie
Im nächsten jahrhundert treffen ein einschlag wäre dramatisch mit einem durchmesser von rund 500 metern hätte, er die bucht von
80.000 euro schirm bomben es wäre absolut verheerend jetzt hat die nasa zusammen mit dem kernwaffen labor lawrence livermore
national laboratories das projekt emma
Gestartet was es damit auf sich hat und ob es die erde retten kann das jetzt den klicks in science fiction herzlich willkommen
Am elften september
1999 wurde der aktion benni entdeckt er ist einer von unzähligen asteroiden die in unserem sonnensystem
Ja man muss sagen die hier so durch die gegend fliegen vollkommen unkontrolliert denn
Wo wie viele mit welcher flug bahn unterwegs sind das ist weitestgehend ungeklärt millionen und abermillionen
gesteinsbrocken rasen durch unser sonnensystem und dabei sind die zahlen allein für unseren planeten
Beeindruckend es wird vermutet dass etwa eine million us orden sich im bereich der erdumlaufbahn befindet und die gefahren die von ihnen
ausgehen sind größer als bekannt dass ein himmelskörper in die atmosphäre
eindringt und explodiert oder einschlägt kommt nämlich öfter vor als wir denken wie oft das in den letzten
13 jahren passiert ist wurde erst jüngst bekannt wir haben darüber berichtet
26 asteroiden sind auf der erde eingeschlagen in 13 jahren darauf gekommen sind findige wissenschaftler sie hatten die idee
beim weltweiten atomteststopp
Überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es andere größere explosionen auf der erde gab und es waren
26 lediglich ein
Einziger einschlag wurde dabei vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen. Im wahrsten sinne des wortes
aus heiterem himmel jedes jahr schlagen also
Im schnitt zwei größere asteroiden hier auf der erde ein bisher
hatten wir großes glück denn die gesteinsbrocken schlugen
im meer in wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten gebieten ein und verdampften bereits in der atmosphäre
Jetzt hat die nasa mit der gezielten bahn verfolgung von asteroiden begonnen
Im letzten jahr startete ja die neue behörde planetary die fans
koordination diese haben die usa eingerichtet um erdnahe asteroiden zu entdecken und zu verfolgen sie gelten als auslöser von massensterben
Auf der erde alle paar millionen jahre steuert mal ein größerer ast auf die erde zu der das leben tatsächlich
Bedroht die nase hat deswegen das ziel bis 2020 alle erdnahen asteroiden die größer sind als
140 meter zu entdecken denn genau diese könnten der erde sehr gefährlich werden
experten plädieren deshalb immer wieder für eine bessere weltweite zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines koordinierten
Frühwarnsystems und jetzt will die nasa zum ersten mal gezielt die flugbahn eines asteroiden beeinflussen also endlich ist es soweit
Benny wirth der erde zum ersten mal am 25 september 2001 135
nahe kommen dann ist das risiko eines einschlags noch extrem gering die wahrscheinlichkeit liegt dann bei etwa eins zu
2700 aber wie wird die erde dann die flugbahn beeinflussen sie könnte der asteroiden noch näher an die erdumlaufbahn
heranbringen und damit das risiko
Deutlich erhöhen so weit wird es die nasa gar nicht kommen lassen deshalb hat die nasa zusammen mit dem kernwaffen labor lawrence livermore national laboratory
das projekt hama gestartet helfer steht für hyper locity
asset mit ideation mission for emergency response auf deutsch
hyper geschwindigkeit asteroiden entschärfung mission für notfallmaßnahmen
es geht wirklich zum ersten mal darum die flugbahn eines asteroiden
Gezielt, zu beeinflussen er soll von der erde weg gebaut werden ein neun meter langes raumfahrt soll auf dem asteroiden einschlagen und ihn so von
seiner aktuellen flug- bahn- ablenken allerdings so zeigen studien
wären
71 schläge zur effektiven ablenkung nötig und damit müssten
25 jahre vor einem möglichen einschlag müsste damit begonnen werden die physikerin megan brasil ist an dem projekt
Beteiligt und sie sagt dazu wenn viele abschlüsse für eine
erfolgreiche umleitung nötig sind wird die mission schwieriger weil es bei jedem einzelnen abschluss eine fehlerquote gibt
Deshalb wird jetzt über einen einzigen atomschlag gegen die raps oliven
Nachgedacht der nukleare ansatz hat das potenzial viel mehr energie auf eine objekt wird wenn du zu übertragen was die geschwindigkeit und flugbahn
Stärker verändern würde so dass kernwaffen labor das wäre viel effektiver wahrscheinlich würde eine einzige situation
Eben ausreichen die allerdings nicht auf dem asteroiden
stattfinden würde sondern neben ihn
Wenn er als erstes neues zum thema gefahren durch asteroiden und zu allen anderen dem erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen an
vom neuesten video und das garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und mehr themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken dann geht alles
quasi automatisch und natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Asteroiden bedrohen die erde sz day ja ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran